WTF Pewds
Hey! How's it goin guys?
Surprised ya didn't I?
Welcome to LWIAY!
*Pewdie-rex sinks back to natural habitat*
Welcome everybody to LWIAY!
YouTube's favorite show and your's too I hope of course.
Remember to subscribe if you haven't already.
Don't you just hate when people ask you to subscribe?
When literally, it's just been fifteen seconds of the video.
How shameless can you possibly be? Anyway have I told you about my chair? It's a great price
Its only 399! And got matching headphones!
Free shipping if you are in Canada
Shoutout to my Canadian SquadFam. How do you do?
Anyway...How's your sex life?
Last week I asked you to get me some memes which I ask you every single week. This channel is literally just memes right now.
Upvote to remind Felix of the peak of his career.
This is a classic attempt of you guys to try and make fun of me. All right like that was a cringy performance
Why the hell did you sing live when you literally have zero singing talent, huh?
You know a lot of people look at YouTube as a as a great way to make your dreams come true. Go onstage
Have an audience have people that appreciate what you do go out and have fan meetups and meet and greets.
When literally I just want to sit here and look at memes alright. That's all I want. I want none of that
things that disappear when you need them the most your keys your wallet your phone Friday when
You guys are such whiny little
Crybabies fridays with pewdiepie was the show I did back in the day and everyone is like
Literally I could call this show Fridays repeater pie and you'd all be like oh
When it's the same thing it's the same thing it was a show based on community activity
And I brought it back and it's been back this whole time
But you're too dumb to even realize it because you're all just a bunch of whiny crybabies
Someone's murder normal people. They go they come home. They go to sleep
It's actually really comfortable in there the mother art gay
Navy and like
Half of these are not even pewdiepie related
It's great keep it up the life speedify the better alright because the nice complaining and whining
about me black ops 2 black ops 3 black ops for
Backup 30 legit five years ago fine. I made this fake video called black ops for
When it's literally just clickbait, I think I played spyro or something we got free running, and I was like alright
So how do I make that the logo looks looks stupid and realistic at the same time?
I just add another another bar on the logo, and they did it absolute mad land
I predict everything because I'm a genius that's right. Can we bring back that good old meme?
Huh who would win their most trusted name in news CNN?
Don't make me laugh some guy with a broken chair
What do you mean broken chick
But can you dodge this?
Yeah, I can alright my latest video, 4:24, you're welcome
I bet you couldn't make a sentence without a you thought
You just did something here didn't you well sorry to burst your bubble?
but numerous senses could be constructed without employing the first letter of the English lexicon pub G
PewDiePie pub G for kids PewDiePie for kids, that's
Right I Make Really Edgy And Really
wacky jokes that
Jack films
Fans wouldn't even understand the level of My
Comedy, so I made this Android app called 'Pewdifire'
For real?
I gotta check that out. Oh my god. It's right there. Oh my god. It's live what the hell
Doctor you have cancer you're gonna die man. No you doctored
All this time we had the cure for Cancer
And it was memes that makes no sense
The paradox when you had kale for lunch, and the green screen does its job
Yeah, I really appreciate that I have really great editors that really fixes
These small weird things instead of putting more attention to them if you're having a bad
if you're having a bad day remember that a man from Canada known as
bitch'll Angelo uses a GPS tracker of his bike rights to draw pictures Wow
Still don't understand my god, so annoying oh
I get it you edit it in me in my own video
criticizing myself oh how clever
So annoying it's just annoying people like this people like this shit. This is really confusing because I'm wearing the same shirt
There's too many there's too many PewDiePie's in one screen here, what's I?
Sometimes wonder what happened to Falcon never oh look at this and another classic
Week's parody pie after retirement
Legit like I'm already in my retirement
I don't think you guys understand all I do all day is sitting this extremely comfortable chair have I told you about
Anything ahead, and I look at means
Okay, I am already living there retirement life
Guys no bullying, please okay, you should be striking down on bullying videos, so
Please don't bully Miss Piggy. She I don't want her to. New meme becomes popular PewDiePie
Pewdiepie always kills the memes
Twelve-year-old crybabies, please, okay, I have the freshest memes all the time I
Elevate the memes I'm the catalyst of memes alright
I make the memes become memes that's how influential I am okay, so don't come crying with your oh. He killed the meme
Who this is as bad as?
Behind the meme okay accept me for the Messiah that I am instead of hating
"STOP HATING I LOVE EVERYBODY"
we are now entering the second page of means we step it up a bit
These are supposed to be the the middle-class meme
Let's see how they do peer deep I can surely do this but can he do this
Why did they get out this joke has been made a million times legit?
I have fans walking up to me and putting out their hand awkwardly being hey. Hi. What are you gonna do now? Huh?
What are you like come on? I know how to shake a hand
All right, I know how it's done. Please stop wasting my time and spreading your germs to me all right
I don't want to touch you why do you think I meant that the brofist because?
Little as possible human contact misery man breaks into multiple woman's homes to tell them he
Respects them in celebration of International Women's Day Wow can we get a round of applause to?
Jason Augustine everybody a true member of the respecting women society and we salute you
Steve Jobs
Reppin that Tsuki merch come on next thing you're gonna say it
We didn't we ripped off that as well. people still talk about this. I said if I get a hundred thousand subscribers
I will strip on camera hashtag strip for us boots, and I still haven't done it
if
I get ten million subscribers. I will do nudes how about that? Oh, that's sick
Edgar the dog and Felix the Human. Aww Edgar thats so cute
How many children have mental health disorders? That's right? You can joke about a mental health disorder, that's fine
man Edgar got bigger Wow damn buy the merch
Please buy the merch. Where will he come from this time all the interest possible hey?
What's up, guys laying on his $399 chair be sauced I'll jump scare probably answering the door
Oh, oh, oh looks like I was ahead of you little no
Brad the Edit King oh look at that Brad you get to get recognized as well
Too bad no one cares about size
skip ad' 399, and I said skip ad
No no no no no guys whoa
This is strangely hypnotizing oh because I'm Joe okay, because there's the same thing Wow
disgusted creative and unique editing trick to make video funnier
to achieve fake
How about that Brad Wow
Okay, I've seen this one. It's honestly so cool that anime thing in the background
Where is it from I need to know normally?
I feel really weird about Peter Pine tattoos, but I honestly think it doesn't even look bad like it's a proper tattoo
And of course who wouldn't want a pewdiepie tear meme on your skin forever
*reads text*
Leave A Like If You Cried